hi guys and welcome to my guide to the
verac easy achievement Diaries the
reason you might want to do this Quest
is for one you get the verac armor one
you get one antique lamp worth 2500
experience and you skill above 30 uh the
main reason you're going to get 15
battle stabs every day from zap for
7,000 coins each that's going to equate
to about 30k a day in profit and your
skull scepter will now hold up to seven
charges additionally when you're or up
to Coal you have a 10% chance of getting
two that is when you're wearing the
armor and you have a 10% chance of
smelting two bars at once up to Steel
only when you're using the edge full
furnace however for this Quest you will
need two quests completed Rune Mysteries
and the dig site quest for skills you're
going to need 15 mining 13 agility eight
crafting nine room crafting 20 fishing
and five
thieving items you're going to need are
150 coins any pickaxe you can wield a
log any axe you can wield a soft clay
Earth
Talisman a pure essence or run Essence
fly fishing rod uh some feathers and a
regular bone uh items that would be
recommended are a couple teleports to
ver Rock I'm going to use a glory and uh
leather boots and leather gloves you
will need for for the kudos for the
museum section and uh any weight
reducing equipment is always useful all
right let's get
started all right so to begin this we're
going to first go to Edgeville uh just
because it's marginally closer to the
first task we're going to do from
Edgeville you're going to want to run
south and uh we're going to first use
the fishing rod on the uh River Lum
fishing spot to catch a trout
[Music]
once you get to the fishing spot just uh
lure until you catch a trout it
shouldn't take too
long and there we go that should be one
easy task completed now we got two
trouts just for extra assurances now for
the next task we're going to go down
into the stronghold of security uh you
don't need any requirements to get down
here and what we need to do is get
through to the second floor most of you
should have already done this uh so if
you have you can just go through the
portal and then down the second stairs
over here if you haven't done this
you'll have to run through the
stronghold of security uh but it doesn't
take very long okay so that will the
second task completed afterwards we're
just going to climb up the
ladder and back
out now we're going to go south to the
pottery ear down
here use the soft clay on the potter's
wheel and we're going to make an unfired
Bowl now take the unfired bowl and use
it on the pottery
oven
and there we go we have created a bowl
that is the third achievement diary
completed okay from here we're going to
teleport to
[Music]
verac so we're going to be on the
lookout for a stray dog but to start off
we will go and buy a
newspaper from
Benny how much a newspaper
cost 50 coins yes please I would like
one
that is another achievement di completed
from here we're going to go down south
towards uh tsa's fine
clothing and we're going to trade
TSA that's all that another Diary
completed from here we're just going to
go south uh towards Southern vck now the
stray dogs are all around uh so if you
just have a look around for a while you
should be able to find one
and one's right over here so we're going
to use is use the bone on the Stray Dog
I'm running away use the bone on the
Stray
Dog and that should complete another
easy
task from here we're going to run
south and out of the city
completely
run down south past the pa uh the path
with the dark Wizards on them make sure
not to get
attacked keep going south follow the
path around and we are going to hop over
the agility short cut
here and just jump over the
fence get a really nice run for this one
and that was a nice jump and that is
another task complete from here we're
going to keep following the path right
pass the quest
marker we're going to keep following the
path up north back towards
Rock and uh we're just going to go and
mine an iron ore from the uh
Southeastern
mine there we go that is another task
complete
from here we're going to go north
following the path
still we're going to go left in through
the
[Music]
gate from here we're just going to go a
little bit
South and here's the t- stall all you're
going to do is steal from the T stall
and that is another task complete we
also almost got us the even level from
here we're going to go a little bit left
and down towards Arbor's auber's magic
shop from here you're just going to
teleport in
here and that should be another easy
task complete from here just run out and
get teleported out from any of the
portals
from here we're just going to run out
and north towards uh the
[Music]
museum keep going north pass the bank
and then hang right and go into the
museum all right so in the museum there
are a couple ways to get kudos now you
need 50 now completing the Dig set Quest
is the easiest way um so all you're
going to do is come down here go south
through the
Rope he should let you in yes I'll go in
and you will need the Dig set Quest
completed for the quest I believe and
also for later verac achievement Diaries
it's better to just get the Dig set
Quest completed so what we're going to
do is spin the camera around and go over
here to the tool tray here we're going
to grab a
TR a rock
pick and a specimen brush uh now it also
looks like you could get the leather
boots and gloves if you don't already
have them grab the uh gloves and the
boots now you're going to need to equip
the gloves and the leather
boots now all you have to do is come
over here to the uh specimen rocks grab
one and use the unclean find on the
specimen table you're going to clean it
and reveal a artifact now you need to
get five specific artifacts there are a
bunch of junk ones in there as well um
but the five that you want are the
ancient coin the old coin the ancient
symbol pottery and the old symbol so if
you get something you don't need just
drop it go grab another one and repeat
this until you have achieved all five of
the items so I'll meet you back here
when I get them
all okay so we have acquired all the
pieces now this can take a a while it
took me about half an hour uh but once
you do have all of them you will get the
pottery the old symbol the ancient coin
the ancient symbol and the old coin from
here click and show them to any of the
archaeologists here they'll tell you
what case to put it in so the button is
going to go in case
22 the old
symbol is going to go into case
36 the ancient coin
is going to go into case
44 the ancient symbol is into case
37 and the old coin is going to go into
case
45 so after you've spoken to him you can
leave the digite
area
and now just have a look at the cases H
click on the ones and it'll show you
case 36 so case 36 is going to be the
old
symbol so just click on it and use it on
the
case next we're going to
case
45 case 45 is the old
coin click and use that on the
case from here we're going to case 37
case 37 is the ancient
symbol next we're going to case
44 case 44 is the ancient
coin and last up we're going to case
22 uh which is for the
pottery all right so we have placed all
of the artifacts in the cases
afterwards once you have placed all of
the artifacts in the case just talk to
curator he Halen and say do you know
where I can find some treasure and then
exit the conversation and you will have
completed another easy
diary from here run out of the
museum and South along the path and
we're going to exit verac
[Music]
again keep following the path over the
city
at the fork go north up The
Path and hang it east at where the path
Forks now we're going to keep going
north up here and there is the Earth
alar
Here use your Earth Tiara or Earth a
Talisman on the earth altar if you
manage to actually make it there
once you're in here just use your
renesance on the
alter and that will be another task
complete once you're done exit the Earth
alter now go a little bit more North and
speak to the Sawmill operator and buy a
plank we're just going to buy one
regular
Plank and there we go another easy task
complete from here just go a little bit
East and um hop over the agility
shortcut from here you're just going to
chop the dying
tree and there we go that is all the
task complete we can now go back to
verac and complete the task okay we're
back at Toby uh Toby is just a little
bit south of the main verac plaza we're
going to talk to
him all right the Diaries are complete
so we have a lamp first of all uh we're
just going to use the lamp quickly and
we'll toss it in
agility that's 2500 agility experience
pretty good uh but the main reason we
did this diary is for the free battle
slabs uh we're not the free but the
battle slabs we're going to get every
day and they're just going to be from
zap all you're going to do is click on
claim staves from the battle staff
barrel and uh yeah you can see you can
get 7K battle stabs and 105 coins in
total that is 15 battle stabs on the GE
can sell those for about 9k each so it's
a decent but diary to get out of the way
all right guys I hope you enjoyed my
first quest guide if you did please
leave me some uh feedback if you thought
it was good or if there's anything I can
work on I would appreciate your input
all right guys see you guys in the next
[Music]
video h